hello boys and girls your favorite
fireman here Oh No
Holy Smoke have you heard the news I've
been stopped from helping my brave
friends in one fire service because I'm
a man yup
I've been hosed because I'm a fella just
what the blazes is going on with
Lincolnshire Fire and Rescue Service or
they were quick to fire out their
rationale but I'm not being inclusive
enough and I'm even putting women off
pursuing a career as firefighters oh
those dots clearly don't watch my show
otherwise they know about my friend
firefighter penny Morris who trained at
Newtown Fire Academy with me and Elvis
and is now putting out fires in
pontypandy no this is plain and simple
PC grandstanding after all
if someone can be put off signing up to
be a firefighter by a large foam mascot
of a cartoon character you have to ask
if they're really up for the rigors of
the job but while this has got me
climbing up the pole with anger I'm not
taking this lying down I've had talks
with postpone Pat and father Christmas
and you can't rule out concerted strike
action the Prime Minister yesterday I
mean how do we go from there Nick Nick
as firemen Sam do you think fireman sam
puts women off becoming firefighter
nonsense it's ridiculous I mean it's
also you've got to have male role as a
man male role models and female role
models we got Dora the Explorer and
postman pan anyway well I mean what I
was thinking as you were doing that is
yeah suddenly this image of the
Grenville firemen we're making it be
serious for a second I was reporting on
the ground the day after the ground for
fire tan and in the few days after that
and I saw Danny cotton who's the female
head of London Fire Brigade I saw
Cressida dick on the streets she's the
head of them female head of the Met I
saw Theresa May on the street she was
the female prime minister at the time
she was shepherded around you know but
she didn't have such a popular visit
yeah and then we have these female
leaders completely means that this sort
of debate is absolutely irrelevant of
course we don't need to have the phone
Fitz
we love farming salmon it's thank you
I'm gonna bring Karen in but it's
interesting that you would mention dora
the explorer' because if we're not
careful this could happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
PC pledge Phil we saw fire fighter Sam
antha Post person Pat Trisha my personal
favorite Bobby the non-binary builder
and Doran the generic Explorer Karen I
love farming Sam I think it's great and
our children brought up with farm and
sand and I just as Rachel said I mean
Danny cotton the London Fire
Commissioner is a woman yeah but here's
the reality whether you look at the fire
service in the UK throughout England
five point seven percent of firefighters
of women if you look at the armed Armed
Forces
the Armed Forces well the statistics
that are there are very few women in in
some cases it's single-digit but it's
certainly under 10 percent now on the
other hand I've just been appointed an
honorary group captain in the Royal Air
Force which I'm very proud of do the RAF
has just appointed an Air Marshal sue
gray who has been appointed as an Air
Marshal the highest-ranking woman in the
Armed Forces and that's happened this
year so you know we we do have women at
the very top quick you're gonna love
this Nick but I was chairman of the
company they're not only cold fireman
sam but we also own Thomas the Tank
Engine
so I now go about who they sell to and
there is no doubt they sell massively to
boys yeah and to parents of boys and not
together they do sell probably yeah
well when I was a journalist we used to
cool thing called flam's that will semi
made-up well look at you have accepted
that they did it if you are the five sir
if you have the fire service from
somewhere and you say we want to get
more women then you might do something
like this and say we want that's not the
best way of attracting women his well I
fear I might lose a character you in a
moment where I might lose part of the
room
the quicker you quoted 5.7 in some
instances some women simply won't be
strong enough to be firefighters the
idea that they could carry me down a
ladder very very applicant blazing
building very few women could do that so
we'll never get it to fifty fifteen I
don't think you saw him we might not
even get it to fifteen that's the
reality great this is the choice of an
employer who's looking to change the mix
I mean again when I was at London
weekend we did London's burning where we
had a very strong female character with
part of the intention was to say yeah
women can do this chocolate ok certain
women can't um very few women can hear
coulda what could the average weight of
120 pounds cut an average weight woman
carry a fully charged fire hose which
weighs a hundred pounds could she carry
it to a site half a mile away where the
fire is - no she couldn't could she get
a bloat light year down 11 this I'm so
but all this box ticking and quotas and
diversity should not come in to fighting
fires but everything that matters in
firefighting is the ability to save life
there was a government mr. Minister said
recently that the fire service had to
reflect the people it says no it doesn't
it just has to put out fires and save
lives and if the best people to do that
hablen I can't wear them that word I
agree with you I'm 3/4 of the way to
agreeing wrong way definitely something
that Gregg said because when you and I
were growing up I mean it was you know
the punchline of a joke was the pilot or
the doctor or was was a woman you know
because it was assumed that if you're a
pilot or a doctor you have or a surgeon
or consultant you're a man and I think
that you know Gregg is it's interesting
what Gregg says that we do still have
very gendered professions
and actually we're going to have to hear
from Lincolnshire which is to explain
why they have taken this move to remove
cuddly Fireman Sam can we just hear this
is we're not using fireman sam at our
fire station open days anymore even
though we believe the program itself
gets across importance fire safety
messages to children we feel using the
mascot of fireman sam on his own doesn't
reflect the fire service today we'd much
prefer people to come and talk to our
fire crews and learn more about the
valuable work they do can you read that
speed well you can pick up on Carol's
point the fire service should reflect
the community that they work with well
and to reinforce another point that you
made it's they have to pass very
rigorous tests physical tests as well as
other tests to be able to do the job and
here's the irony at the same time the
Lincolnshire Fire Service has done this
there's been a record number of female
applicants 700 West Midlands 36 percent
of applicants they dropped away because
they knew they realized they couldn't do
the the fitness test and we mustn't
change the fitness test to accommodate
well no because that will cost lives
yeah but some men file with predators
well and there are lots of other jobs in
the fire service than article that can
be done by women I mean we shouldn't you
know this is you do matter culture
you're talking about right how do you
encourage more women to go into certain
sorts of jobs and if that's if that's
the intention of the organization in
charge then it's perfectly logical
they've done this but anyway let's just
have a quick listen to the guy who
created fire also have got I call David
Jones firefighter is an Americanism it
is in the British Way it's like a yeah
I'm a superhero character when I'd like
that we don't do it that way so I think
the firemen Sam has done a very very
good job whether it's outdated
I don't know possibly it is and whether
it would stop some and putting the fire
brigade because it just is a fireman we
put fire
women in there by the way I think that
is the best word for that is nonsense
it was a real diamond fine except the
course was originally made by in Wales
it may by s4c Wales the brand is now
represented by Mattel and this is what
Mattel say Fireman Sam is a much-loved
an iconic brand we're constantly
evolving to make sure that we stayed
true to the show's heritage as well as
representing the world that children see
around them today the team are always
referred to throughout the show as
firefighters except Sam whose title has
not evolved in his role as the show's
namesake women are equal to men in every
aspect they're not physically then not
equal and we can't pretend that they are
and put them in a fiery uniform and send
them to fight fires if they're not
physically capable of doing it all men
and women come in 250 I've joined sense
to it since 2010 how would you like to
see more children girl children
represented in in children's cartoon
programming CBeebies and whatnot say
that more girls eaves and feet will they
I you know I think well the Teletubbies
that occurred to me they will
gender-free weren't they you don't think
it's an issue you don't think it makes a
difference what's going on we're
avoiding the reprimand Sam there were
some jobs that women okay
I'm gonna have to move his on rugby
stars are normally known for their
stellar performances on the pitch but
legend Gareth Thomas made history of a
different kind this week after he became
the first sports person in the UK to
publicly reveal he is living with HIV
the former whales captain says he was
forced to make his diagnosis public
after being blackmailed but rather than
be a victim Gareth is now pledged to do
all he can to support other people with
HIV and help break the stigma
surrounding the condition here is his
brave admission I want to share my
secret with you why because it's mine to
tell you not the evils I'll make my
he'll threaten to tell you before I do
and because I believe in you and I trust
you I'm living with HIV now you have
that information that makes me extremely
vulnerable but it does not make me weak
now even though I've been forced to tell
you this I choose to fight to educate
and break the stigma around this subject
Gareth there's no doubt in our minds for
your courage and conviction alone you
are our hero of the week